comparution à joliette aujourd'hui de
guillaume gélinas est accusé des
meurtres de son père et sa belle-mère
jeudi dernier à terrebonne zilina un
ancien militaire aurait soigneusement
planifié ces deux meurtres
jacques bissonnet
guillaume zilina 22 ans un ex militaire
est apparu dans le box des accusés vêtu
d'un simple t-shirt gris une nouvelle
ère absolument pas nerveux paraissait
même plutôt calme détendu et n'a fait
aucun commentaire
alors il est formellement accusé d'un
double meurtre prémédité meurtre sur son
père luc que zilina 54 ans et sa belle
mère julie lemieux 35 ans une partie des
preuves été divulgué son avocat maître
menu et vous comprendrez pour des
raisons évidentes que je ferai pas de
commentaire sur la preuve à charge
ah si un drame pour plusieurs familles
amis parents alors évidemment ces gens
là tentent de vivre le deuil
solidairement et en privé donc on
demande la collaboration de tous
je lui même se sent très affecté par ce
qui se passe je commenterai pas sur ce
que comme un monsieur ce sera le drame
est survenu jeudi dernier dans la
résidence familiale à terrebonne lyon me
zilina habitait chez son père il a été
interrogé et arrêté jeudi soir dans
l'outaouais
là où habite sa petite amie et sa mère
biologique
un double meurtre bien planifiée selon
la police mais sans mobile apparent pour
l'instant aucune demande d'évaluation
psychiatrique n'a été fait c'est trop
tôt dans les procédures
guillaume gilles hinard reviendra encore
ici au palais de justice de joliette
le 6 mars prochain pour connaître la
date de son enquête préliminaire
issigeac bissonnet radio-canada joliette